[Music]
today i'm going to show you how i clean
47 years of dust out of vents
[Music]
as soon as we walked in we see the old
vents the furnace how old it was before
even opening any of the vents up i knew
how bad it was going to be you know he
said 47 years of dust probably over 100
years to be honest
if you look at a vent and you see
dust
on the actual vent
that's a clear sign that the ducks have
probably never been cleaned and they're
pretty filthy inside uh we like to start
on the very top of the house and work
our way down
that tool that we're using uh we call it
whiskers
the whiskers are just made out of rubber
the end of it's attached to an air
compressor and you have air just coming
out through the rod
out the little whisker things
[Music]
so what you're looking at right now is
just me pulling chunks of dust out
that have probably been in there for
over 100 years there was too much dust
to be putting it in the vacuum
um so i literally went in there with my
hands and grabbed probably like five
pounds of dust
isn't it gnarly like look at how much
dust that is
it's just
so sick honestly
[Music]
this is the back of the dryer and you
guys could pretty much see
there's an endless amount of light
coming out
there's a few reasons why you should get
your dryer vent cleaned it's a huge fire
hazard and your clothes will dry more
efficiently
it's well worth the money to just pay to
get it cleaned every year
the vacuum is on
throughout the whole process
uh and what we're doing is blowing all
that dust and debris closer and closer
to the vacuum
this house in particular had 18 vents
most of the time i think
probably 75 of the time
the
houses that we go to have never been
cleaned
um people just don't think about it you
know that getting your air ducts clean
isn't like a regular thought that comes
to your
you know head the dust you typically see
in your vents is most of it is actually
uh human skin cells
yeah it's pretty gnarly
so right now we're done and everything's
pretty much good to go um you're pretty
much gonna see
a brand new home honestly uh you're
gonna feel much better
uh your health is gonna be better i
actually got a phone call after that job
and they said all all their allergies
went away
it's just a huge health benefit honestly
uh you might not notice like the small
stuff but your body does